[Music]
previously on the x-files
being somehow oblivious to the six foot
three 245 pound man sneaking about your
laboratory look i get that hopper knows
some shady shit's going down but to be
honest the consistency of said is
totally unknown to him which makes
walking into this quarantined area
without any sort of safety gear an
extremely questionable move is jim
hopper
chief jim hopper
yeah i've got jim hopp okay the radio
someone to confirm i meant to be here
bluff enabled hopper to disarm the first
dude but i've got no idea how he managed
to get the drop on the second guy who
really should have already had his gun
ready to go drink
i'll calm your nerves
and help you think straight yes please
give me the thing that makes it illegal
for me to drive to help me think
straight even in the 80s this was known
to be dumb advice don't look at me like
that what like how everybody is looking
at me like i'm out of my damn mind
considering the thing she's claiming is
that a demon monster stole her child
while she was communicating with him
through a membrane to a nightmare
dimension hidden in her living room wall
a couple of sideways glances are
probably fair you remember your aunt
darlene no
no
this is not
that well then here's a sim for not
giving us a flashback of that one time
crazy aunt darlene beat up the milkman
mailman and garbageman on the same day
because she thought men in uniform were
challenging her authority how am i
supposed to calculate the level of
joyce's sanity if i don't have an
example of and arlene's peak craziness
well
well
well will five episodes in and matthew
modine's hair is still a sin upside down
what'd she say upside down what
upside down come on kids say it one more
time you might be able to summon the
beetle gorgon this is where will is
the upside down
like the veil of shadows
also something that's always bugged me
is how our favorite nerds manage to nail
what the upside down is based on the
smallest slithers of information they've
gathered so far i mean all they know is
that will is missing somewhere that's
dark strange and sort of familiar they
combine that with eleven saying upside
down and make the leap to extra
dimensional mirror land instead of
assuming will is being hung from his
ankles in his own basement the veil of
shadows is a dimension that is a dark
reflection or echo of our world and to
top it all off this belief is reaffirmed
by a literal work of fiction it is a
place of decay and death as opposed to
our regular dimension where nothing ever
decays or dies also dust and narration
well
well i wish i had hopper's ability to
let my sense of adventure take over my
sense of self preservation no dusty
decay flaked hallways of an underground
lab can stop this man for where there's
no will they're somehow still away
i guess you can't get a good read of the
situation unless you stimulate at least
four of the five senses despite having
plenty of time between the sitting of
episodes four and five whalen and zade
and duffer have ignored the public
outcry to reveal themselves take that
down
it's inappropriate evil dead poster
shaming you look nice sweetie
complimenting someone who is going to a
funeral on their choice of clothing this
room is lamptacular kind of get the ones
on the bed post i mean they're pretty
cool but why did will's room also need
one here and here damn it i bet that
globe is even illuminated
wait should we tell will that jennifer
hayes was crying at his funeral for
anyone who thought sam nudging steve to
check out sharon carter and captain
america civil war was the most
inappropriate funeral scene ever
stranger things would like you to hold
its dry eggo waffle paranoid character
tears up their house looking for
recording devices cliche oh cool and a
random blade works as a lock pick cliche
one more cliche and i get a free you'd
better come take a look at this bumper
sticker bumper sticker what you can tell
someone but they're not gonna believe
you
you know that your mom would jeez nancy
learn to read the room this is not an
appropriate time for your mom dig also
if his goal is to make sure his mother
doesn't go through any more trauma could
i be so bold as to suggest not risking
the life of her last remaining offspring
but what if right next to her acrobat
there is
a fleet now the fleet can also travel
back and forth just like the acrobat
here's where things get really
interesting they do not
what are you doing what does it look
like i'm doing being the worst handyman
ever first of all hanging some drywall
would have helped the hole on the inside
of the home and then the boards can be
put on the outside until you can get
someone out to repair it fully second of
all nailing eight nails in a cluster on
the right and two on the left is all
kinds of tim the tool man idiotic and
gets you two extra sins i told you not
to take these down they were in the way
babe calling any woman that you aren't
in a relationship with babe do you even
understand how a compass works no one
understands how a compass works dustin
no one but god help me i will keep these
lights up until the day i die my yearly
outside christmas lights mantra somehow
makes its way into this episode i cried
for a week
i'm a fan of thumper this kid is alive
during the golden age of disney animated
movies and his favorite character is
from bambi the years 1983 which means
you have movies like robin hood the
jungle book the rescuers peter pan and
the fox and the hound yet you reach back
to a boomer aged movie to grab your
favorite character from okay with the
times kid you'll be left back at black
cauldron while we're watching toy story
yes he and my mother love each other at
some point but skip
this is not how you answer a phone i
know technology's changed but as a child
of the 80s i can assure you the correct
procedure is to state this is the hopper
residence my brother is a fart nugget
how may i direct your call how do we
know when we get to the gate oh i think
a portal to another dimension is going
to be pretty obvious dustin would be
zuul at tv sins minority reporting your
child yesterday with the cameron he's
not like that at all
yesterday yesterday episode expects us
to believe that only a day's pass and
steve broke jonathan's camera they found
will's body and had a funeral since then
get the [ __ ] out of here with you
yesterday nancy oh i was just starting
to think you're okay believe it or not i
actually have a limited amount of skips
per episode and if this show isn't
careful with the amount of divorce drama
alcoholic cop drama and teenage drama
drama i'm gonna have no skips left for
when we eventually send euphoria maybe
to get moved
no i don't think it's the gator why why
couldn't it be the gate messing with the
magnets it could be underground a mile
in the sky or the [ __ ] car over here
dustin my dude you're easily the
smartest kid here but you have zero clue
how this gate will present itself ten
minutes
there's blood i knew it was come on i
saw her wiping her nose on the tracks
she was using her powers admitting to
being able to have done this
interrogation hours ago saving enough
time to find the portal in my desire to
send the rest of this episode
okay
should be okay or you could leave the
[ __ ] house right i mean this is the
sort of search you can never be
satisfied as complete is this a watered
down cerebro these scientists must have
never read an x-men comic if you want to
infiltrate people's minds all you need
is a big room a bald head and the desire
to sit hit by a car what car do you know
of that has teeth [ __ ] nancy this
street could be in the middle of disney
world and pin gillette could be inside
tempting me with a pack of oreo thin
mints and a brad bird signed edition of
the incredibles and i still wouldn't
crawl into the damn thing but nancy just
goes right on in all alone as if her
friend's younger brother and her own
best friend weren't missing and presumed
dead
you know what evil lurks in the hearts
of men for you have seen that evil in
your own heart
what's your name again the name's bond
james bond you're never going to catch
me
you're wasting your time forget about it
go do something else
see your next meal hey kid would you
please leave without a fuss right now
all right well i don't know who's been
raising you but i'm gonna get you some
new crayons
because it looks like he's shooting
cabbages
i'm hungry let's get a taco supposed to
hit the cans right there was no baby it
was full of cats
i cried for a week
tiny baby man
we've been trying to contact you
regarding your car's extended warranty
loud noises